Tucker Carlson predicts hot war with
Russia to defeat Trump in election he
was speaking to Adam Carolla and he said
they will do anything to win so how do
they do that they're not going to do
covet again whoever on the right is
afraid they're going to do covet and
mass mandates they're not going to do
that Carlson told Adam Carolla they
can't do that they've already been
exposed that won't work there's going to
be no what are they going to do they're
going to go to war with Russia it's what
they're going to do there will be a hot
war between the United States and Russia
in the next year
yikes that's uh strong words coming from
Tucker and it is a contrast to what
we've talked about what many have said
because we are seeing mask mandates come
back yes however
he may be right
the covet game is played I think I agree
with them there that it's just it's
going to be with us forever now it's
going to be mutating and it's you're
going to have lesser dangerous strains
lesser painful ones and then every once
in a while one will mutate that's like
kind of hard but there will be like oh
but it's like the flu and that's the
question the question is will they try
to use it for political think about the
thing Tucker he when he I watched him
interview Donald Trump last week I don't
know if you guys saw the interview at
the very end he's like so do you think
there's going to be civil unrest and
he's doing that Sullivan not where he's
nodding and I'm like geez what is he
trying to incite like and Trump is just
like I don't I don't want to even answer
that like you could tell and Tucker's
like civil unrest and he's nodding like
I don't just why is he
I don't know why he said that I don't
know what that that we're going to war
with Russia I don't know why he said
that well for one is it the fact that
there's a war in Ukraine and we're
funding
Russia already that's not formalized so
he thinks I mean let me let me let me
let me help you out let me clarify
let me help you out I'll clarify for
Tucker Carlson they're not going to war
with Russia he's wrong what he should
have said is they're going to formally
announce we have been at war with Russia
and try and act like it's just begun I'm
concerned about Total War I can
understand the proxy war like Vietnam we
thought the Communists in Vietnam we
didn't want to bomb Moscow because we
don't know Washington to get wiped off
the map and if we go to war with Russia
we're going to annihilate our each of us
and then China will take over the world
like what or India and China will take
it over slow down there we're at war
with Russia right now it we already are
and so what do you guys think will
happen uh in the election cycle
well they're definitely going to bring
the the kovitz coming back I mean I I
don't know I mean I already see people
talking about Mass mandates at school at
schools um they're they're definitely
going to start Joe Biden's talking about
a new uh vaccine yes to be funded a
whole new one that's gonna work this
time he says and uh yeah weird thing to
say and it's inappropriate mind you yeah
yes inappropriate for Joe Biden to say
that
I mean it actually is I don't think Joe
Biden who cares what's it appropriate at
this point I I honestly think that Joe
Biden is like a smoker kid right he's
much like Weekend at Bernie's right now
and someone's holding them up with
strings and walking them around the
stage I honestly I don't know I I think
that they're gonna they're gonna try to
push the the mandates back I think
they're gonna try to mess with people's
jobs again I really do and I I but I
think that you know the American public
many of the people who fell for it first
time are not going to fall forward again
but so so the way we've described it is
or what we've predicted
they will issue guidelines they'll do
something like you cannot discriminate
against someone who seeks who decides to
quarantine but no one's forced to
quarantine but then businesses will need
money to pay for employees who don't
want to come into work and don't have to
then they'll issue another kind of PPP
or whatever the guidelines because they
know they can't do a hard lockdown
justify an expansion of universal
mail-in voting I wouldn't be surprised
if they outright legalize Mass ballot
harvesting under the guise of covet
there's no doubt that that's that's part
of this push I mean they definitely want
they want mail-in voting as much as
possible look the Democrats the
Democrats are going to do anything they
possibly can to win uh I just don't
think they can do it with Biden but but
covet is not out of the realm of
possibility to force this election to be
done through melon voting I don't think
that we're in we're not talking in a
vacuum right now like millions of people
are listening to us and if we make
enough noise ahead of time and shock
people out of the stupor they won't we
won't even get off the ground we have
agreed I spent two two full years
rallying against the stuff on my smaller
podcast and and definitely the big
podcasters the big shows have got to
push this uh you know Mass it was I I
think so Scott Adams said the first
company to do this we must bankrupt yes
absolutely stop buying all their
products and and Bud Light and Target
them in the exact same way I read that
van Gardens and uh BlackRock are getting
out of ESG they're down to like three
percent yeah but that just means that
they're looking for another thing to
call they're fine it's something else
yeah absolutely interesting they're not
gonna give up on the goal no right so
and that's something that that people on
the right and people that are involved
in in you know whatever you want to call
the culture or whatever you need to
understand like even if like BlackRock
and Vanguard and all these these um
investment bankers and stuff they they
get out of the ESG uh model they're
going to be looking for something else
to achieve the same goals because
they're ideologically modeled well you
made a good point there with the with
the fact that um they're not gonna
they're not gonna change the goal the
goal is always going to stay the same
and that's what worries me about the
Russia thing right is that if kova
doesn't work there's a damn good chance
would they use a hot one what do you
think is the goal with Russia
the goal with Russia right now I
honestly I think that it's to push them
towards the the One World Government I
mean if you want to get really deep into
Alex Jones
there are there are two dominant Global
factions yeah NATO and Bricks sure
what's the what's the idea we need to
crush them because Brix is our enemy
no
I don't you're not gonna you're not
gonna get Russia to fall under NATO
influence right because they're they're
they're not going to they just want we
rush every week right right I think it
may actually just be more so
they're not thinking about it in terms
of we must defeat Russia because
Russia's enemy it's
we must reduce Bricks by seven percent
sure yeah sure and there's seven percent
of the population I mean seven Russia's
like seven percent is the people calling
shots are like and if we reduce the
United States Power by 20 in order to
reduce Russia by seven percent then the
Swiss Bankers win right but we've talked
about this though there's there's a lot
of in my opinion there's substance of
the argument that the established you
know order right now is changing the
whole lucidity's trafficking that we
talk about and it seems to me and I've
heard the argument I forget where I
heard it but I'd see but it seems
reasonable to me that the goal of the
people that are like in the wef and
stuff like that um and the UN stuff the
goal is to
do a soft Landing with the United States
as China Rises and the intent is in this
is to keep the whole world out of World
War III but if they can have a soft
landing and lower the US's
um living standards in a way that
doesn't cause too much chaos in the
United States and also at the same time
support China so they can raise their
their level of influence and stuff and
manage that without having the US and
trying to go to war that I think is the
goal because the the the Chinese model
in my opinion is what the people like
the wef and stuff was what they want to
Institute in the west because they have
essentially ultimate control over the
population have you have you guys seen
that uh Eugenia Cooney video she's the
uh yeah social media influencer who
weighs probably 13 pounds
literally maybe like 40 pounds yeah and
uh like on the verge of death anorexic
right and and she's apparently got like
like 8 million hits on Tick Tock people
are begging her to get help and all that
stuff but it just it reminds me of what
the war actually is right now you have
influence from China to destroy the
younger Generations in this country
these kids I saw one story already
someone said that their younger sibling
stopped eating because they wanted to
look like Eugenia it's the it's the
Opium works if they're not using actual
physical opium they're using technology
yeah they are though I mean that's
coming to the southern border so that's
happening too yeah does China want to
destroy America you think that China
wants to destroy America or they just
want to weaken it so they can have ten
we get 10 more power in this I I think
right now what the the global powers are
looking at is I just want them to be
weaker than us so we have the dominant
position it's almost like a Sumo match
right but it could eventually lead to a
fist fight and it seems like that's
where we're going now as for Tucker
Carlson predicting hot war with Russia I
think it's funny because if you actually
talk to him about it and said right but
we're at war with Russia he'd say well
yes of course of course yeah and then
he'd expand upon the idea the idea being
the U.S will formally declare war or
they'll find a reason to do it and uh uh
it's it's going to be some kind of false
flag not with Congress though of course
not it's gonna it's gonna be unilateral
it's going to be a NATO uh NATO uh
Article Five sure so false like this is
what they did in Vietnam they did a
false flag to get us to go to Vietnam to
fight a proxy war against Russia right
uh so you're thinking now they're going
to do a false flag to get us go fight
the mainland Russia like yo we're going
to invade Russia I know there's I the
idea of the United States putting boots
into like Russia no what about not on
Alaska I mean it's what is it like 100
miles away from Russia no there's not
even up there 50 miles or so there's
nothing else the Aleutian Islands
stretch all the way like very very close
to Japan but think about listen think
about what you're talking about though
like if if Russia invades Alaska right
they have to go over the Rockies to get
to Mainland to the lower 48. or they
have to invite Canada yeah they have to
go through Canada and they have to go
over like this is not they're going to
be slipping on maple syrup yeah
listen I've I've traveled through the
Rockies out there you blow up passes and
you shut down any advance okay you can't
drive tanks and stuff like that through
the mountains without roads that's
that's just not happening could they
take the coast it is not happening like
what about three on the flip side China
invades Alaska for resources
you can take all of Alaska yeah yeah but
I mean I mean how many people are are in
Alaska there's like 250 000 in the state
I think we'd have no choice but to
respond with a maximum military force oh
yeah if there's an invasion I don't I
don't I don't think there's no waiting
around I decimate the opponent in that
situation maybe not invade I think to
let's get let's get specific in the
event that China Russia or whatever
these these brics Powers invade Alaska
that's a long shot for a variety of
reasons but they do I do not believe
that
um ICBM nuclear weapons will be launched
over that however don't be surprised if
you see
nuclear artillery yeah you know to be
honest with you like not that I not that
this the idea of anyone invading Alaska
is more compelling now that we're
discussing it but if there were a
situation like that Alaska is the type
of place where using uh tactical nuclear
weapons uh would make sense there's
nobody around very small population yeah
there's nobody around and if you if you
see a column moving you know take them
out I met offensive like counter offense
tactical Nuclear letters like on Russian
cities the Russians in those United
States
but but hold on this is the problem with
nukes the Russian government attacks so
your response is to vaporize a million
innocent civilians right right we can't
do that and that's why I don't think the
nukes go flying this this idea that in
the event of War we all start firing
nukes at our at our at our cities is
just like
they're trying to control the cities
they're trying to control resources
nobody wants to I would say for the most
part most people don't want to rule over
the ashes but they don't want to be
subjugated either the only reason you
would see nukes fly is to destroy
military targets so you may see New York
in some way devastated by a massive
nuclear attack or some kind of advanced
attack I believe it's more likely at
this point civilian targets will be hit
by Massive cyber attacks what we saw
with the ransomware where you have like
these the the train system the whole
network goes down because all the
computers get encrypted instantly the
pipeline
exactly how did they take out nordstream
the CIA how did U.S intelligence and
Western Powers take out nordics
conventional explosives
a lot of explosives like again
apparently the uh it's not that hard the
pipeline was like encased and kind of
like it's not just like a tube like it's
a big deal right so there's a lot of
look you don't it's underwater you blow
it up yeah you don't need a nuclear bomb
to blow up a pipe right but what I what
I think we'd be more likely to see is um
Callum mentioned it there was that Cyber
attack on that uh that that Pipeline and
that basically shut down gas supply in
in the Southeast and people don't
remember that it's kind of like yo that
could be War yeah and you would not know
the the risk is
in the past Gulf of tank and Vietnam the
U.S wanted the American people to think
we were attacked to justify public
support for a war right today there's
good reason not to get forced into war
because you want to be prepared for one
and if you're not you don't want your
economy disrupted so the US is not going
to come out and be like that Cyber
attack that was China because that would
mean the people would rally and demand
retaliation which we may not be prepared
for however that being said the US
government could very easily Cyber
attack a water plant or a pipeline
disrupt the flow of energy in you know
the Midwest in Chicago or something
millions of people are in Desperate
Panic water is not pumping out of their
you know there's no electricity or
whatever and then they say
that was China we found Putin's passport
I like that I like that line of thinking
because we're listen we us podcasters
and guys who do shows we're constantly
talking about who's our biggest enemy
who's our biggest these guys are These
Guys these guys are gonna attack
thermonuclear war are our biggest
enemies right here man you know what I
mean like the the American government
can do whatever they want they could
shut off our resources I mean it's it's
pretty you know it's pretty scary to
think about what they could do to us we
have a correction John uh John Curry
says Phil there's over 700 000 people in
Alaska the chat is upset they're mad at
you I apologize
you're in Alaska bigot thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time